[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  won't you move him as long as I'm the  big spoon  I love you  [Music]  it's perfect  [Music]  oh boy berry-berry you're gonna be late  almost beats there we've all the time we  want oh yeah  [Music]  good so much water do I wanna kiss me  goodbye  from now on we're partners in serpents  in life all of it okay  I am ready to be a partially kept  [Music]  [Music]  I'll never forget you  [Music]  did you mean everything he said or did  you just say it because the world was  ending I really want to play this cool  but I'm afraid that I'm gonna ruin it if  I try to be sexy I already ruined it  saying the word sexy is not sexy  [Music]  this isn't real yes it is  that's talking more kissing  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]